the fastest way to change your habits is
to change your environment you ever
noticed how when you're in a different
environment maybe you go on vacation
maybe you go to an event or seminar you
start doing different things you are
still you and you do some of the things
that you used to do but all of a sudden
you're doing new things that become a
part of your regular routine you ever
been away for a couple weeks and
discover that you built up some new
habits and maybe some are healthy maybe
some are unhealthy and so if you want to
be able to switch your habits quickly
you change your environments now you may
not always be able to go on vacation or
go to events or seminars although those
are options but it starts with you
figuring out what are the habits that
you want to develop who are the people
that you want to be around and when you
are around those people you will start
to think differently which will lead to
you behaving differently when you see
other people doing it you're going to
want to do it more when it's in your
environment more you're going to want to
do it more too hey it's Nina car Michael
and we made these videos because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you need that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan carmichel and learn the
fastest way to change your bad habits
enjoy this morning I was talking to a
YouTuber big YouTuber bigger than me
more subscribers than me slightly
different Niche and I remember meeting
him in California a couple years ago and
one of the things he was struggling with
was staying consistent and I'm very
consistent and one of the things I was
struggling with was staying healthy
while I was on the road and we were
having dinner together and he was eating
super clean he was eating fish and salad
and I probably had a burger or something
fries and coming away from that what I
realized
was whoever is more confident wins and
when you're around other people
whoever's more confident in the habit
that they have will be the dominant
habit that both of you end up picking up
so if we were hanging out together more
here's what what would happen I would
become a lot healthier in my eating and
he would become a lot more consistent in
his content because we'd be inspired by
each other because he'd see me working
away make my videos and he'd feel bad
that he wasn't making his and he'd have
to go and start making his and I see him
eating healthy all the time be like man
I should be eating healthy and it would
force me to do it as well that
environment switch would allow us to
create much better stronger habits so
now you got to be careful about the kind
of people who you're hanging out with
and if you look at the people who you've
got right now around you chances are
they're keeping you stuck they're
keeping you small they're keeping you
where you are and you're probably
pouring into them right you're the one
giving them love giving them
encouragement giving them
support pouring to them you're you're
taking your cup and pouring it to them
and it's great and it's and you should
keep doing that and it's amazing and
it's it's fulfilling but who's pouring
into you and who's making you get to the
next step uh because if you don't have
that you're going to you're going to
continue to stay small or just have slow
growth compared to where you could be so
how do we get some practical steps okay
that's great what what do we actually do
how do you start making that change
happen well the first step is to figure
out what is it that you want to get
better at you know what area of your
life or business do you want to be
better at uh is it you want to stay more
consistent on your habits you want to
you want to learn how to make money you
want to have a better relationship you
want to take care of your health like
what is the thing that you actually want
to get better on getting Clarity on what
that thing is two is to then surround
yourself as much as possible with with
content not even people because it it
could be great to say hey awesome hang
around Joe dispenza all the time and you
will you will become better you will
meditate more you will Sol your awesome
but you don't know Joe dispenza and he's
probably not taking on students right
now or mentees right or Elon Musk or
Oprah winf whoever right you don't know
them and so that's not a practical
answer but you can hang around their
content it's why I make these videos
every day because if every day there was
a new video for you hopefully it lifts
you to bring some of the best experts in
the world the people that I find
inspiring and learn from to share their
message every morning you don't have
that person in your life but there's
videos for you so step two is so step
one we're figuring out what is it that
we want right where do we want to
improve and get better step two is who
are the people who are who are living it
who are preaching it who are living it
who actually inspire you and there's so
many different people out there who are
doing it and everybody has their own way
I like to say that you know an Eric
Thomas is going to yell at you through
it and open Winfrey is going to hug you
through it but they have very similar
messages whoever style you connect with
the most have that more consistently in
your environment follow them on
Instagram subscribe to them on YouTube
put their quotes on the wall around you
create your own environment of the
people who make you feel like you want
to do more who inspire you to step out
of your comfort zone and take on those
new habits that you want to actually
adopt right so you're creating a new
environment for yourself without having
to go live with Joe despenza or Elon
mosco wire okay so I call them
aspirational mentors and and it that can
be fundamental and that's where most
people need to start because you have
access to their books and their videos
and their content you have that access
right now and that can make a big shift
in you if you start surrounding yourself
with it every day and then step three is
to is to get more in-person connections
and this is more time consuming and more
challenging and harder to find the right
fits but can make a big shift as well in
your life so I don't want to only rely
on that's why step two is actually
having just content that you're learning
from but step three if there's people
that you're learning from do they have
an event do they have something coming
up can you hang around people who are
like-minded who are also taking on
challenges I'm doing a challenge right
now inside my M makers program where M
makers is For Thought leaders who trying
to get to the next level with their
content and and break through and have a
greater message and reach more people
but a lot of people haven't been as
consistent as they should have um
because they're the only ones doing this
they don't know anybody else making
content their family thinks they're
crazy like why are you making another
video they're not seeing results that
they don't have a peer group they don't
have anybody to connect with and talk to
and this can relate to any goal that you
have Movie Makers is just for kind of
thought leaders making content but
whatever goal that you have if you're
the only one that you know who's doing
it it's really hard to stay consistent
on it so our movie Maker's challenge is
every month we have a challenge where
you have to make a lead magnet for your
business a solo video and then three
collaboration videos with other people
in the group so it forces you to start
making content and for a lot of the
members this is the most consistent
they've ever been now in making content
because one they're doing it together
you feel like you're doing it with other
people even though a lot of the content
that you make um outside will still be
separate from the members you're not
doing a business together but it feels
like they're connected we're taking on
this challenge together and then in the
collaboration videos you're you're
you're connecting with people you're
doing interviews with people you're
you're sharing your thoughts and
feedback it's not just you talking to a
camera in the car with your dogs by
yourself
anymore and that really really really
really matters it really matters so
getting some kind of support group
connecting with other people who are on
the same Journey going to seminars or
events of of humans that you can talk to
connect with who are doing the thing
that you want to do cuz the more that
you're around those people the more
you're going to stay consistent on the
habits that you want to build so using
that three-step process can absolutely
change your life it's it's entirely
possible and if you're watching videos
like this you're you're already on the
growth mindset Journey right you're
already into personal development you
already know you want to do more and
serve more and help more and this helps
you elevate yourself to the next level
because you are probably the most
ambitious person that you know that
you're hanging out with and and that's a
great place to be because you're serving
and helping but it also sucks because it
limits your growth of what you could
become where if you can one clearly
identify what do you want to change what
is the Habit that you want to take on
where are you not satisfied anymore in
your life not beating yourself up and
saying you suck but like the next level
of growth that you want to accomplish
for yourself and then two following
people just through content who are
living that message who are who are not
just speaking it but living it who who
when you watch their their videos you
actually get inspired to go make a
change in your life who are those people
subscribe to them follow them every day
watch their content read their books put
their stuff up on your wall as a
reminder you're creating a new
environment for yourself and then three
is actually connecting with humans
joining a group like Movie Makers or
something else going to events where
you're your tribe is at so that you are
not alone doing this journey feeling
isolated and like like you don't belong
make those three changes it will change
your life the difference between where
you are now where you could be it's just
the consistent habits that you're
putting in you know this I know you know
this now it's about taking the actual
action to stay consistent on those
habits Rule Number Two Become efficient
the number one rule if you want to make
more money is you have to bring more
value want to make money quickly provide
value quickly want to make tons of money
provide tons of value if you not making
money yet is because people don't see
the value that you bring and we're going
to change that in this video so one of
the first people that I had any kind of
arrangement with on the top 10 series
that I had on my channel was Tony
Robbins I made a video on Tony Robbins I
don't know how many years ago now the
the first top 10 that I did on him and
his team put it on his YouTube channel
so it may still be there if you go to
his YouTube channel and then look at the
playlist you'll see that one of those
videos is the video that I made on him
all so many years back and I started
trying to bring as much value to his
team as possible now Tony's a really
busy guy uh i' loved him from all the
books that he's written and and the CD
programs that I listened to I hadn't
been to an event yet at that point and I
was just trying to bring value to Tony's
team I didn't know him personally yet
and it frustrated me that he wasn't more
on YouTube and I thought hey this guy
needs to be on more on YouTube I want
more content for my channel and I just
think I think the world needs more
amazing speakers and thought leaders out
there creating content on YouTube so
people can learn and so I kept in touch
with this team and I said hey I'd love
to help promote Tony I'd love to help
you with your YouTube channel I'd love
to have Tony on my channel and and I
just kept trying to find ways to bring
value to his team consistently and
following up and finally here's what
happened finally they agreed hey yeah
let's have Tony come and do an interview
on your team and finally they said hey
on your channel and I was so excited I
was super nervous I have Tony Robbins on
my channel it's going to be a big deal
and and then like the day of or the day
before he had to cancel for for
something happened something came up on
his schedule no problem he had to cancel
and all of the nerves and energy is like
oh no now now led to disappointment that
is finally going to happen and then it's
not going to happen and he said we'll
try to we'll try to book it in as soon
as possible to get to get it happening
cuz Tony wants to be on your channel
great it took two years before we
actually got Tony on the channel
afterwards two years and and that's not
that's not the sh to Tony I love him he
he's busy he's doing his own thing I
wasn't bringing enough value to to make
it sooner uh but what I did was I kept
in touch I I kept following up not just
saying hey is Tony ready yet hey is Tony
ready yet hey is Tony ready yet no I'm
bringing value I'm helping them with
their YouTube channel I'm giving them
suggestions uh I'm helping promote their
events I was doing stuff to try to still
be in the circle to stay top of mine so
that when the next opportunity came up
which happened to be when he launched
his next book to say I want to be top of
of mind and Tony agreed to do five
different remote interviews uh for the
for his new book and I was one of the
five and and his team said you've been
so valuable to us you've been helping us
so much we appreciate it uh we want you
to be one of the five that Tony does at
an interview with like it's happening
it's h Pinch Me for real this time I
hope it's happening and then the day up
he showed up and and and I was super
stressed out and nervous about asking
the right questions and trying to bring
value again I don't want to disappoint
people and uh and it went he showed up
it went great we had an awesome
interview and at the end he then said
hey Evan uh I'd like to invite you as my
guest to my next uh seminar which is
coming up in uh New Jersey unleash power
within and he invited me to like front
row seats special lounge access and all
all the perks uh meet him backstage
because he wanted to chat and take a
picture which then led to more events
and other opportunities and then
speaking and then you know connecting
with Brendon Bard's team and like lots
of stuff happened through the Tony
Robbins world and
connection because I stayed and I
followed up because I kept trying to
bring value and even after the first
time when they got the cancellation on
me I still followed up for two more
years and kept providing value for two
more years right it's dog on the bone I
want this to work I'm going to find
another way through until finally it did
and then things took off and so the same
thing for you and your business if you
want to have success it's about thinking
about ways you can provide more value
it's not that you can't provide value
it's not that you're not talented that
you're not a genius you are people just
don't recognize the value that you can
bring yet and you haven't figured out
how to bring that to Market in a way
that you're going to get paid to do it
okay so my three-step process so that
you can provide more value and get paid
what you're worth let's go step number
one is build your top 50 list think
about who are the 50 people that if they
knew you if they liked you if they
trusted you if they respected you if
they recognized who you were and and
knew what you were up to that that would
mean something right for a lot of people
it doesn't matter if they know you or
not they're not going to be a referral
source they're not going to be a partner
for you but who are the 50 people that
matter most that that you would love to
have as dream clients or dream
Partnerships build that list of 50
people that you want to make contact
with step number two is be their chief
goal officer if you want to have success
and this isn't just for the 50 list but
for your clients for your team for your
relationships be the person's chief go
officer when you understand not just
what you want but what they want and you
help them get it that's when the whole
world opens up the reason why I was able
to get to to work with Tony Robbins and
his team was I made a video at the
starting point right I made a video that
they like that that put Tony in a good
light uh that was respectful that made
him look as well as a as a as a business
Guru on top of everything else that he
was already doing and then every
interaction I had afterwards I'm
bringing them value I'm helping them
with their YouTube channel helping
spread the awareness for programs and
courses that he has coming up right I'm
trying to be a a resource for them but
around things that they care about not
the things that I want to talk about
it's what they care about and so if
you're following your 50 people right
you have your list of 50 pay attention
to what they're talking about try to
catch them when they're in a time of
need right so classic examples are when
somebody's pitching a book or when
they're pitching a new deal or where
they're trying to get eyeballs on a new
show that they just launched like what
are they talking about if they've gone
super dark and super quiet and they're
not active on any of their social
platforms it's really hard to start to
make an entrance one of the people on my
list has just gone dark and we've had a
good relationship with the past two
years and now he's gone dark he's he's
in bookwriting mode it's like I'm in
bookwriting mode now and I'm not going
to surface for the next four months so
I'm not going to send him anything in
the next four months he's not going to
be posting anything for the next four
months there's no point in me reaching
out and seeing how he's doing in the
next four months cuz he doesn't want to
be bothered but but when he resurfaces
and comes up for air you know what he's
going to need he's going to need
promotion he's going to need marketing
he's going to need support you know
who's going to be there this guy right
like that's the process if you promote
my book right now it just came out I'm
just in launch mode I'm trying to get
eyeballs on it right if you promote my
book right now if I'm on your list I'm
way more likely to reshare your stuff to
to share the post to pay attention to
who you are then in 2 months if you did
the same thing and that's for everybody
everybody's going in these Cycles what
do they care about most right now what
matters most to them right now and then
you finding a way to be a resource to
help them so that they know who you are
they recognize your name and say that
person that person's awesome I love that
person when you get to that point then
when you reach out with an ask when you
say hey I'd love if you could XYZ
they're way more receptive to you
because of all the value that youve
brought be their chief goal officer
understand what they want and help them
get it and then you can ask for what you
want and setep number three is then just
constantly follow up with value where
most people quit is they don't get an
immediate response the more successful
the person is that you're chasing down
the harder it's going to be to reach
them the harder it's going to be to
penetrate them right so you have to
consistently follow through right like
just look again at my Tony Robins
example took it took a while to get that
first interview that got cancelled they
promised to do another one and it took
two years before that next one happened
of of constantly following up right not
not every day but couple times a month
con constantly sending some value
pitching ideas helping them with their
YouTube channel always through Tony's
team to the point where it's like this
guy Evan is bringing us so much value
once Tony's opening up his calendar
again we have to make a spot for him
right most people quit too soon would
you wait you know a year to get the
first thing and then two years before it
actually happens right another two years
would you wait that long would you
follow up that much like if you're on a
a short timeline and that this business
has to work in six months and you're
going to sell it to do something else
this isn't the strategy but if you're on
a lifelong path like these are people
who you want to work with these are
these are your Heroes who you can't wait
to get in front of then you have to
follow through you got to stay on it be
their Chief gold officer but don't give
up after the first time if you're not
getting results right if you DM me and I
don't respond the first time if you
leave an amazing comment and I don't see
it like that's going to happen you're
going to get lost in the shuffle a lot
of times and especially if you're only
doing it once but if every time I go
live on Instagram you're there ask
asking great questions showing love and
support when I went live on YouTube
talking about my book if you were there
right asking questions showing love to
the people if you bought the book and
shared it with your story right I'm
going to notice you and and forget about
me maybe you know who cares about me
great the next person Gary ve or Tony
Robbins or Kevin Hart or Will Smith or
Oprah whoever the person is that you
love the most right your top 50 you're
constantly paying attention and at any
given point in time not all 50 of them
are going to need something but
inevitably somebody on that list right
now needs something they need help they
need support they need Outreach they
need marketing they need exposure you
can help be that person for them and
then they're going to remember you the
constant NeverEnding ongoing Outreach of
value to build the business that you
want to build also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there r
number three make proper decisions you
need to make the big decisions in life
with your heart and the small ones with
the head big decisions with the heart
small ones with your head why because
your head only understands a world that
currently exists it's logical it's
practical it keeps you safe but your
heart can create something new that
hasn't existed before it's why the
number one rule for success is Follow
Your Passion all progress depends on
what your heart tells you to do and then
you use your head to figure out how to
execute it so I just got back from an
event that I was keynoted in Florida and
I was meeting these two entrepreneurs
and helping them with their YouTube
channel and one of them is a really
logical head first guy and the other one
is a more heart-based passionate guy and
they were they were asking me so that
they're Partners in the same business
and they're asking me what's more
important logic or emotion logic or
emotion and they obviously the guy who's
logic based thinks logic is the most
important and the guy who's emotion Bas
thinks emotion is most important right
you want to think that what you're great
at is the most important thing and I
told them it's macro emotion micr logic
macro emotion micr logic you need to do
both so as I'm looking at their YouTube
stats I'm going deep into YouTube I'm
telling them all the data that they need
to know I'm looking at the numbers and
explaining your audience retention sucks
here we need to fix it the percentage of
subscribers coming to your channel is
too low all of this stuff we're going
we're going deep into all their
analytics I can talk talk numbers for
days I love numbers I love making data
driven decisions but it's not the macro
the macro is the heart the macro is why
are you on YouTube right why am I on
YouTube why am I making videos that's
the macro and then you use your head to
figure the how the science of the
thumbnails and the audience retention
and the playlist and the titles and all
of the micro strategies that you can use
on YouTube to grow but it's macro motion
micr logic and so as I was explaining it
to him as I said it was listen it's
macro emotion he said but but I was
listening to you as you were explaining
things to me it was very logical like
yes the tactics were very logical but
the delivery so that you would
understand it and then go home and
actually apply it is emotion it's not
logic it's emotion because logic can be
everywhere the answers can be everywhere
you know how to lose weight you stop
eating junk you know how to get fit you
start working out you can find it but
why people not doing it because you
haven't connected emotionally the reason
why you understood what I was saying and
you're willing to take action is because
of the way that I delivered the
information to you because I had you
control the mouse and go through and do
it yourself because I was encouraging to
you when you needed it and I hit you in
the face when you needed it too not with
my hand with words right it's macro
emotion micr logic you need both to win
but just recognize the situation you're
getting into your big decisions with the
heart and then you use your head to
figure out how to do it so it's common
when you come with a new idea for
something you make a list of pros and
cons right and that's your heart often
talking against your head where you have
this giant list and you say well these
are all the reasons not to do it but
there's only one reason why I want to do
it and so if it's 10 con and one pro
what do you do if you just look at
numbers you go for the con but maybe the
one reason why is you just love
it when your head and your heart are
working together it's easy when your
head and your heart are opposite that's
when it slows momentum that's when
nothing happens because you want to do
it but it doesn't make sense to do it
you really love it you have to do it but
it's no There's no practical logical
safe sense to do it you need to get them
aligned your heart needs to say listen
to me brain we're going now help me
figure out how to get there we're
jumping now let's figure out how to make
our parachute on the way down that's how
it is big decisions with the heart small
ones with the head I'm going to give you
a three-step process that will help you
step number one is use the fear of
regret the thing that can jolt you in
action is to use the fear of regret
imagine your yourself 90 years old
looking back on your life and this
moment right now is the pivotal moment
what happens right now this decision
you're about to make right now will
change the entire course of your life
what will you regret least right and
then go do that one or what will you
regret more if you don't do it right and
then go do that one because the fear of
failure the fear of judgment the fear of
whatever the people are going to say all
goes away when you can extend the
timeline out when you imagine that
you're 95 years old then this decision
right now will set the course that if
you decide to do the small thing the
safe thing and then you hate your life
for the rest of your life because you're
worried about what your mom was going to
say it puts it into perspective it makes
the future pain so big that it forces
you to act and so whenever you're faced
with that decision ask yourself what am
I going to regret if I don't do it step
number two is pay attention to what
excites you and this is especially when
it doesn't make sense what excites you
what what makes you want to go what
makes your heartbeat like what makes you
get up and want to
move often times it's not the thing that
makes the most sense because again your
heart can create a world that does not
yet exist but your brain only
understands a world that currently
exists so it keeps you safe logical and
practical so pay attention the things
that excite you think about the last
time you were really excited what
happened what led to that now how can
you attract and bring more of that into
your life a great example for me is when
I took over Toronto Dan salsa when I
started salsa dancing it didn't make
sense
I'm tall I'm learning as an adult I take
big steps I don't speak Spanish I don't
understand their music all of these
cons I just liked
it it excited me right I wanted to go
back I couldn't wait for my next lesson
even though there all these things
against it practically it made zero
sense and now I own the largest Salsa
Dancing Studio in Canada maybe North
America because I liked it so pay
attention to the Energy pay attention to
the activities that you're doing that
even if they don't make makes sense you
love doing because if you keep doing
work that you love you'll get good at it
and you'll become top in your industry
and then set number three is you quit
when you don't love it anymore people
ask me when do I quit when do I give up
there's all this advice never give up
never quit that's not true you should
quit a lot but you quit it when you
don't love it anymore you give up on it
when when it's driving you nuts a lot of
entrepreneurs stay in the business for
too long even though they don't like it
anymore because they're they don't want
to quit but you will never win doing
work that you
hate if you haven't found success yet
and you still love it you have to keep
going you have to keep going or back to
rule number one you will regret it if
you quit too soon if you felt like you
quit too soon you gave up a little too
soon you're going to regret that your
whole
life but if you've already grown tired
of it even if it is making money for you
then find a way to sell it or find a way
to get out of it because you should be
doing work that makes you come alive
that gives you energy that you love
that's the only way you're going to make
a difference rule number four worked
hard hard hard work is your ticket in it
doesn't guarantee your success there are
tons of people who work hard and are
living at the poverty line but there is
nobody who wins and doesn't work hard
working hard is your ticket in one of
the biggest reasons why I've won on
YouTube is because I've been making
three videos a day for the past five
plus years three videos a day for five
plus years there there have been one or
two days where maybe I missed one video
not three videos not an entire day day
off maybe one video once or twice in 5
years that's it it's just been a
testment to consistency every single day
videos have to go live on the channel
and I filmed through everything I filmed
through having broken my neck right in
two spots I filmed through having a
concussion I filmed through being sick I
filmed through completely losing my
voice and then having to to pull up
pieces of paper with the notes written
on and I film through everything I think
there's a lot of people who who I look
up to who I think are way better than me
people who have way more Talent than me
who are way more natural than I am at
making videos and expressing themselves
and I've passed them because I just
worked harder because I just kept going
because I kept making the content one of
the the biggest reasons why you are not
more successful is you're just not
consistently working hard enough at it
this game of Entrepreneurship whether
you're trying to be a YouTuber or
something totally different it's are you
getting up every single day and doing
the thing that you have to do because
you're going to get punched in the face
there's going to be so many setbacks
even today this morning my wife had a
rough night last night she had allergies
she woke up at 400 in the morning had to
to take some pills and just had a really
rough night and and that set us back on
our morning routine right we have our
morning routine we go through our 5 and
a half s's every morning uh we start off
with with singing we'll put some music
on then Sun then soar and then sweat and
then scare and we got set back back by
half an hour by by her having a late
night and this is where so many people
fall down when you have something that
throws you off schedule right when
you're sick when when life hits you in
the face when a distraction comes up an
emergency happens how do you respond
because if you only work hard when you
have ideal conditions you're never going
to build a great business we were set
back half an hour today right what do we
do the same 5 and 1 half
let's go how you respond matters and so
whatever is happening in your life right
now there's so many reasons why you
can't win there's so many reasons why
you you you shouldn't get up and work
lots of reasons reasons that are
justifiable the reasons not to work on
your business are justifiable and if you
ask your friends who are
non-entrepreneurs or at least
non-successful entrepreneurs they'll let
you off the hook tell your friends yeah
I lost my voice like oh you can't make
videos you tell your friends I broke my
neck oh yeah yeah you can't make videos
right they'll let you off the hook but
these are not the people who have
standards that you aspire
to don't allow the low standards of your
friends prevent you from doing the thing
that you should be doing and so how you
respond to these emergencies and these
life situations that happen matters it
means
something you with less Talent right you
might be introverted you might you might
have less Talent you might have less
skills you might not be naturally gifted
at it you can win
this is how you win by working hard
every single day are you proud of your
effort when I was still on my tour even
though I broke my
neck my quality wasn't as high post
breaking my neck versus pre-breaking my
neck in terms of doing the workshops but
I was proud of my effort are you proud
of your effort and if you can
sustainably say that you're proud of
your effort if you can wake up every day
you know my wife is tired
today she'll take it a little bit slower
today but is she proud of her
effort are you proud of your effort if
every day you wake up and then you do
work and you're proud of your effort I
promise you you're going to win if you
can sustain that for weeks for months
for years you'll win where the problem
for too many people is you're working
really hard one day and then you fall
back and then really hard one day and
then you fall back and that applies not
just to entrepreneurship it's life
you're you're really hard working on
your diet and then you fall off you're
really hard working out in the gym and
then you fall off it's the consistency
that matters it's the working hard every
single day you are what you consistently
do and I want to see you guys win okay
great so how do you actually develop a
brutal work ethic I'm going to give you
a three-step process you can follow
let's do it step number one is you have
to do something you love right I mean
you can only force yourself to do
something that you hate for so long
before you give up of all the people
that I profile right consistently across
a Athletics to Entre R preneurship to
politicians to musicians singers all all
across the Spectrum people who've had
success the number one rule that keeps
coming up over and over and over and
over again is they love what they do you
have to enjoy the process you like the
work I like making videos I like
speaking entrepreneurs right I like it
if you are forcing yourself to do
something that you hate you will quit
you just will it's going to be too hard
and so why spend all this time doing
work that you hate just chasing some
opportunity when you could actually
Focus those efforts on something you
love to do and get results that nobody
else can you have to do stuff that you
love number two is tell yourself that
you do difficult things this is how you
build self-love this is how you build
self-confidence this is how you build
self resect you do difficult things you
like to do difficult things and and it's
not just a mindset trick like you
actually do you don't want to live the
same life over and over and over and
over and over again you don't want a
boring life you don't want to just stay
inside your comfort zone and so to leave
your comfort zone that requires doing
difficult things and so whenever you're
looking at a challenge that's in front
of
you you're looking at a goal that's in
front of you you're looking at an
outcome that you're trying to go after
and Chase what's the reason that you're
telling yourself why you can't do it if
it's well it's difficult that's not an
acceptable reason catch yourself and ask
your friends and your family the people
close to you to catch you too anytime
that you say well that's hard that's
difficult and you do things you need to
change the wiring you like doing
difficult things the fact that it's hard
makes it amazing you don't want to do
easy things for the rest of your life do
you do you want to just do easy things
for the rest of your life no you want to
do difficult things you love difficult
things so watch the language watch the
words you're telling yourself watch your
thought process if the reason why you're
not achieving your goals is because it's
hard it's difficult that's not a good
enough reason cuz you do difficult
things and then idea number three is be
the tree I love using this analogy the
idea is you're a tree you're an
entrepreneur you're a tree what do trees
do well trees they breathe in carbon
dioxide right poison they breathe in
carbon dioxide if you have too much as a
human you will die from carbon
dioxide they they breathe it in they eat
it right they eat it they grow from it
and then they spit out positivity oxygen
for the world that's your job that's
your job as a leader that's your job as
an entrepreneur your job is to eat the
negativity to eat the poison to eat the
difficulty and then create something
better for the
world it's service whatever this
challenging thing is that you have to
deal with whatever you're trying to work
so hard on whatever you need to develop
a better work ethic on when you do it
you'll be able to help other people do
it as well and if you believe like I
believe that humans are built to serve
then you're going to be able to help
other people because your purpose comes
from your pain because the thing that
you struggle the most with once you
figure it out once you get get through
it what will make you come alive for the
rest of your life is helping other
people who are currently going through
that thing so you're a tree this is what
you're meant to do this is what you're
born to do this is what you love doing
you're supposed to breathe in the poison
eat it Grow from it and then make the
world around you a better place rule
number five the last one before our very
special bonus clip listen to your heart
it's not fair you're right it is not
fair the situation that you're in the
people around you the lack of resources
that you have it is not fair I agree
with you so now what because you have a
very important choice to make the past
does not have to equal the future where
you started from does not have to be
where you end up all of your Heroes
overcame bigger obstacles than what's in
front of you right now so now what are
you going to take accountability and
create a new life or keep complaining
about how your current life is not fair
let me tell you a quick story story
about friend of the channel Alex sayen
who helps me run Toronto dance salsa
Alex was a student at TDS for a number
of years and badly wanted to be a helper
helpers are Advanced students who then
help volunteer their time to help out
the other students he was rejected he
was rejected over and over and over
again that he was not good enough to be
a helper finally he got accepted to be a
helper his next step was he wanted to be
assistant then he wanted to be an
instructor and over and over and over
again while people are getting promoted
and giv up opportunities Alex just
didn't have the material Alex kept
getting said no no no no no you're not
ready you have to fix this you got to
fix that you're not good enough yet keep
going home keep working on it eventually
he got to the point where Sharon who was
the original owner of the studio said
okay Alex I'm going to train you to be
an
instructor years after where most people
would have been given the opportunity
Alex finally earned his way in it's easy
for him to have said hey it's not fair
why are are the people getting
opportunities ahead of me hey it's not
fair on me but he kept going he kept
working he kept grinding then disaster
struck finally he got that opportunity
right to be trained to be an instructor
and then Sharon the lead instructor hurt
her back and couldn't train with him so
she asked me to come in and help teach
the class there's a problem though you
can't have two guys at the front of a
class I couldn't dance with Alex that's
not traditionally how classes are
run so Alex Was Defeated finally had
worked so hard to get this opportunity
and then he realized I'm going to have
to go back to just being on the
sidelines cuz evans's going to come in
and teach the class now I didn't think
Alex was
ready I had known him for a number of
years I didn't think he was responsible
enough I didn't think he had What it
Took but because Sharon had made a deal
with him I decided I would honor that
deal and on the day that he came to pick
me up to go to the studio I said Alex we
got two options the class is happening
tonight either I could run the class and
do it and you can sit on the sidelines
and watch or you can run the class and
I'll sit on the sidelines and I will
guide and Mentor you you get to pick but
you have to decide right now cuz we're
driving the class and we're going to be
there in 15 minutes what do you want to
do and to my not just surprise but also
admiration he said I want to do it he
wasn't quite ready to take on the whole
class but he said I'm going to do it and
he went up and he did it was it amazing
no but it was momentum and he kept going
and now fast forward to today if you
gave me a brand new salsa student and
said this person has to learn salsa and
I wanted to have a fun time doing it I
would put money on Alex over anybody in
the world to give them the best possible
experience I would from a guy who I
didn't believe would be a good
instructor to now being the best in the
world how well he had to overcome all of
these things that weren't fair he had to
overcome growing up having super sweaty
hands and not being able to touch a girl
so he never learned to dance until
became an adult he had to overcome years
of people passing him by getting
opportunities ahead of him because he
wasn't good enough he had to overcome
waiting to get his chance to be trained
to be an instructor and then finally
here it is it all happens and it looks
like the whole thing is going to get
ripped away from him because the woman
who was training him couldn't teach
anymore and then he had one shot and
that's all it takes you will get your
one shot you will get your one shot if
you keep going you will get your one
shot if you take accountability you will
get your one shot what do you do when
you get your one shot but you feel like
you're not ready
yet cuz that's the pivotal moment where
you can decide I'm going to fall back to
the life that I had or I'm going to step
forward into a Brave New World that I
don't know how it exists yet and I'm
scared and I'm not ready but I'm going
to take it
but if Alex told himself it's not fair
that all these things have happened to
me he would never got his one shot it
wouldn't happen get clear on what you
want what do you want make it super
clear you can't just want a better life
what does that look like get super clear
on what it is that you are going after
write it down one sentence make it clear
for yourself make it clear for the
people around you make it clear for
anybody who comes in contact with you
say hey what do you want this this is
what I want I have absolute Focus and
when people look at you and say you're
never going to do that look at where
you're coming from that's okay cuz you
have direction right the world gets out
of the way for the person who knows what
they want you need to get clear on what
you want get it down to one
sentence I think people struggle with
goals because they struggle with
self-awareness because they don't know
who they are and so they're constantly
adjusting the goals that they have for
themselves based off what other people
think of them and based of what they see
out in the media or on Instagram or on
YouTube
they don't have self-awareness and so
you set incorrect goals and so here's a
three-step process I call the higher
purpose plan that I think if you go
through will dramatically change your
life it did for me it did for many
others and it's time for you it's time
for you to have meaning in your life and
build something amazing so let's go step
one is your who you got to figure out
what your one word is what your most
important core value is who are you as a
human being I've wrote a whole book on
this but just as a quick brainstorm
opportunity for you right now think
about what is your single most important
core value what is it if you have to
pick one core value as a human being
what is it for me it's belief I like
believing in people I need to believe in
people I hate negativity I hate toxic
people I hate the haters right I don't
want to be around people saying that you
can't do this I am the opposite I need
to believe and so already right there
already having that awareness of what
your one word is what your who is when
you figure that out it allows you to
make better decisions it means that if
you were in a work environment if I was
in a work environment where people
didn't believe in each other I wouldn't
I wouldn't be able to handle it I would
be frustrated be upset i' be angry and
now I know why because my one word is
believe and so what is your single most
important core value figure that out
it's one of the most important exercises
you can ever do in your life it's super
helpful it's valuable it's important you
need to do it otherwise you will never
have Clarity over your goals step number
two is your why why do you do what you
do your purpose comes from your pain
your purpose comes from your pain the
thing that you will enjoy the most in
life is helping people who currently are
going through whatever you massively
struggled with think about the biggest
pain in your life whatever that was
growing up the biggest pain the thing
you never want to have to repeat or go
through again that pain that pain that
deep dark pain you wouldn't wish upon
your enemies that pain the worst day of
your life that pain your greatest joy in
life will be helping people who are
currently going through that pain and
getting them through it that's it that's
your purpose for life that will never
get old that will be with you for life
and so for me starting up as an
entrepreneur was my biggest pain I I
felt worthless I was making $300 a month
I was suffering and struggling and just
felt defeated as a human being that's
why I love helping out other
entrepreneurs and that's going to be it
for life that'll be my purpose for life
and so I know my who I know my my one
word most important core value I know my
why my purpose comes from my pain that
is for Life guys just figuring out those
two steps will give you so much more
clarity over 99% of the world it's worth
it it's a little bit of process to go
through through but I guarantee you it's
worth it it'll dramatically shift how
you see the world and what you do with
your life step three is then the how so
it's the who why how how is then your
passion it's figuring out what it is
that you're actually going to do so I
could believe an entrepreneur is all I
want but what am I going to do to do it
you have to enjoy the process if you
look at the most successful people in
the world they enjoy the process of the
work it's not just the end result it's
not just for me about hitting 10 million
subscribers it's the process I like
making videos right I like helping
entrepreneurs and I do that through
making videos through speeches through
books you have to like the process of it
otherwise you will never win once you
figure out your who your one word once
you figure out your pain right the why
purpose comes to your pain then make a
list of all the ways that you have
helped people deal with those struggles
and then Circle the ones that you enjoy
the process of if a friend of mine
needed to move to a new building and I
and I offered to help and move boxes I
would be pumped for him that he's got
his new office set up that's believeing
in entrepreneurs but I don't enjoy the
process of moving boxes and so I
wouldn't Circle that one on my list but
if it's making videos if it's writing
books if it's going and doing seminars
and speaking from the front of a stage
if it's helping entrepreneurs one-on-one
at coffee shops all that stuff I love it
I love it like I could do it forever I
love it it fills me it gives me energy
and fuel and so I want that for you and
so you now make a list of all the ways
that you have helped people and then
Circle the ones that you enjoyed not
just the end result but the actual
process and then figuring that stuff out
you're set you're set you're now a
special human being and I think it's
within all of us to be able to do it we
just don't have the awareness that is
something that we need to go and Chase
down and so figure that out get the
self-awareness understand what your who
is understand what your why is
understand where your how is and your
life gets dramatically
better because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hash believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
and if you want to watch watch Evan's
top 10 rules for succcess check out the
video next to me I think you can enjoy
continue to believe I will see you there
I think your purpose comes from your
pain so whatever you struggled the most
with is what you want to help other
people through so I struggled so much as
an entrepreneur and getting my first
business off the ground and quitting and
having $300 a month and all this stuff
and so I just want to